hey luca shotshop 14
okay was sagt uns jetzt vielleicht etwas
positiv oder so ist ein positiv ground
handling charts und dance act sox
schnell zum positiven rüber kommt mir
schaffen wir das schaffen nicht bereit
bin ich wohl noch okay müssen noch mal
diese blöden hinwerfen
kommt drauf stellen dass dieser
nuklearreaktor dritte 32 karneval dich
okay gut ich dachte besser hinter mir
und ich sind waren die ganze zeit drauf
erst noch einen trank
halte was des kaisers ist eigentlich
verläuft ich freue mich schon gleich gar
nicht also darüber fliegen darf und
samples machen kann
wie stehen wir hier drauf wir können
nicht wollen oder müssen zuerst alle
umbringen aber es kann auch sein
ich weiß nicht ob die märkte das weiß
dass man alle umbringen muss also alle
tot
da wartet s.de zivilen momentchen ruhig
noch ein paar sachen negativ grund weil
dich bald ich weil ich jetzt müssen wir
das positive ist für nicht geschafft
haben habe ich jetzt auch falsch gelesen
henning chen jin choi 2254 dann stand
das neutral auf positive bleibt das wäre
es jetzt
während die positiven starts komm rüber
hey hey aus glas aus russland die amazon
app exchange
in dem schwachen dienst wird ja alles
einfach so einen endboss es einfach nur
eine ecke drin hätten aber eine krasse
rüstung
wir müssen dann die kettensäge von ihm
schnappen habe ich kaputt
was auch nicht
als die waffe stark drei schläge von
diesem komischen das blatt auch nicht wo
wir noch müssen hier müssen wir lange
danger das irgendwie so komisch das lava
wir müssen unglaublich reihen oder so
aber wie nee das kann ich auch nicht
anmachen zentrale der onestep activated
vielleicht auf den knopf drücken naja
okay stimmt
so drückt immer die ganze drauf
jetzt kommen wieder leute hier an
verstehen nicht was heißt jetzt gebracht
die tür ist gar nicht aufgegangen wartet
drückt du mal einfach nur vereinzelt zum
beispiel darauf deaktiviert 1 was
passiert dann eigentlich gar nichts doch
hier ist hier ist es links offen
gegangen kann man mit ihr
jetzt möchte ich auch noch im web geht
eine stunde 1 stunde vorbei echt
hier kann man hochhuth von halo doch
nicht hoch ich kann also einer wenn
nicht erst ab 1 mache kommt so ein typ
kommen wir mal hierhin last dort sind ab
1 202 was passiert jetzt macht nummer
eins nicht mal zwei aber verstehst ich
auch nichts es verschiebt sich gar
nichts vielleicht ist hier irgendwas
nicht sonics ich denke immer noch dass
wir dann irgendwie hierdurch müssen
hier drückt man dort aber einfach so da
muss ich wahrscheinlich da reingehen
einfach einer drückt man dort 12
macht nichts so jetzt wieder 1 oder 2 2
2 war richtig so jetzt wieder 12 ich bin
so ein modell soll jetzt den schalter
ist irgendwas an
natürlich muss auch noch raus ja sie tut
sie auch nein ist sie nicht
ach so etwas eben gedrückt ja so ein
schalter das jetzt noch mal an die das
ist nur dass für vorhin jetzt ist
irgendwie also ich hab diesen schalter
da oben gedrückt
vielleicht müssten aber wort fällt mir
noch schneller sein
das normal probieren und schauen dann
einfach auf die tür offen ist wenn ich
den schalter an die das vitra schalter
den ich umgelegt habe das heißt was ist
passiert
ich weiß nicht was das problem gar keine
ahnung
das ist jetzt passiert natürlich noch
mal probieren
weiter soll ich den schalter wieder
umgelegt was jetzt passiert sonst hab
ich den schalter red door has been
anlockt ok lass mir wieder raus eine
rote tür auf der a8 ich komme wohl die
heftige rüstung alter besser allerdings
diamanten linkies feuer resistenz ist
schon mal ganz gut ja wir müssen da
schon wieder so ein tötete war noch mehr
und dann noch dieser resistenz ich
glaube das passt so ok dann würde ich
mal sagen ist denn die tür offen
ja die ganze zeit offen ich habe acht
minuten das gut
bis so ein talent ich hab's getrunken
hey du verbrennt bei mir die falschen
cadel ist einfach ein richtiger eine
richtige den internen richtungskämpfen
richtige intelligenzbestie das müssen
einfach wissen keine ahnung wie's läuft
jetzt das geld ich kann es einfach den
schalter drücken
ja ich schreibe dir einfach mal von hier
weg gehst du nach unten und schaust ja
ich guck das ist jetzt eine tür offen
nein ist noch keine tür offen doch die
tür ist offen
ja da muss ich dazu die schale und einen
m1 blablabla irgendwas nichts besonderes
ich treffe meine dumme rüstung da wieder
rein die ich nicht brauche diese feuer
resistente du brennst bei mir immer noch
ich kann ja auch noch sollten wir den
ratings also the tentacle der jazz at
the week porträt tentakel set holzdekor
kempe destroyed jake scott ebay softic
tentakel
wir müssen die tentakel irgendwie töten
treffen mit pfeilen vielleicht warte das
da oben
ich probiere mal
ja ich hab das znt siehst du die blauen
kenzo max payne
naja kenne ich aber nicht gespielt egal
wann startet gibt es aber auch so eine
ähnliche mission so ich glaube es
geschafft das extrahieren da oben nicht
triffst du hast dich hab ich hab nicht
sofort ach so als explodiert the doors
down what's inside laufen welche tür
nicht einfach okay
raus hier mindestens im helikopter würde
ich jetzt schlagen agiert nicht
da draußen genau den gleichen weg durch
die noch angekommen sind und jetzt
sollte ich irgendwann hält acht da ist
ein helikopter jetzt weg fliegen könnte
oder so ok schon jetzt wir haben es
geschafft in cortina ist access security
failed
wiederbeleben
im raum
okay das war die mit zombie apocalypse
ist eine der besten adventure maps ich
bisher gespielt habe ich eigentlich sehr
sehr gut gemacht vor allem den ganzen
kommend loks und redstone sachen waren
jetzt genau in vier fahrzeug das
wahrscheinlich schneiden spanien in den
fünf dass es besser wenn wir eine
ableitung des schon die ganze lange
zittern für das paar irgendwie so eine
stunde neun minuten
wenn es euch gefallen hat dürft ihr
gerne eine positive bewertung abgeben
und in die kommentare schreiben was euch
an den liebsten gefallen habe zehn
weitere adventure maps die ich zocken
könnte und welche jetzt würde ich sagen
tschüss von meiner seite auf chips von
kabel und der die verletzten worte